[Music]
joining me today is the founder and
director of turning-point USA a student
organization for young conservatives
which advocates for free markets and
limited government charlie Kirk
welcome to the Rubin report glad to be
here big fan it's great Young
Conservatives I thought there was no
such thing that was like the Yeti or the
unicorn or Falco or something there's
more of us than you might imagine it's
not all conservative summer libertarians
summer free thinkers independence people
on the center-right we just had that
amazing conference that you were nice
enough to come down and speak at in
Florida 2600 700 students from all 50
states
and it was so funny I couldn't pay the
the media outlets to cover this thing
you know that's calling up the New York
Times Washington Post here we had you
know thousands of students giving up
their winter break to come here from you
know you and me and the best speakers
you know that I have a key for freedom
and none of the media outlets in the
traditional media outlets covered it but
it's amazing there is a there is a
revolution happening on these campuses
but it's not it's not against you know
conservatives all this it's it's it's a
new train of thought that we want
freedom we want smaller government but
it's also fighting the culture war which
is for free speech for diversity ideas
and really against what these college
campuses have created yes
so you're in the thick of a lot of the
things obviously that we talk about here
so first I just want to talk briefly
about how we met because I think it's
kind of it kind of shows sort of how you
operate and why turning-point has taken
off so we had met about a month and a
half ago at the Horowitz Freedom Center
event in Palm Springs were you were you
a panelist there yeah I was a panelist
it's kind of helicoptering around a lot
of friends that you know attend that
conference yeah so so you were there and
everyone was like oh you gotta meet
charlie Kirk you gotta meet Charlie Kirk
we met for two seconds you said a couple
nice things about me and you're like you
know we're doing this our gig in Palm
Springs in a couple weeks money to come
down and talk and and then and
immediately we worked it out and and
your guys send me the paper that work
the next day and it was done and I think
that does illustrate something because
we're gonna get into some of the issues
that vary agree on and some of the
things we disagree on but basically you
were like look you're you're down for
free speech that's the main thing here
and I want my audience to hear you talk
about well I you're a rational thinker
which is really rare to find in
California I'm kidding but no I mean I'm
a big fan of the show and I watch a lot
of you interviews and I know you're you
know you have a huge following amongst
young people and I mean I might you know
met you I was like yeah let's get you on
board I'm oh I've always been a gut
player for better for worse it's got me
into a little bit of trouble at times
yeah but I think net it's been positive
you just have to you have to go with
your gut and make quick decisions and
similar that's where I met Candace Owens
too who is now doing a wonderful job
with us and yeah took me about 45
seconds until I offered her a job so
literally I think it happened right in
front of me and then you walked up to
mr. Candace was like I just got a job
and you were like let me do some of the
with you it's like all right look this
guy's obviously open to some different
people it's totally in the schema what's
going on you need the diversity of ideas
right if you if you're in a room where
everyone thinks exactly the same that
would be a university so you need the
university ideas and you need you need
to be able to challenge your viewpoint
around a broader theme of freedom that
really is okay to have that sort of
discussion yeah so to illustrate that
point so then about I think it was the
week before Christmas you guys do this I
was it the largest conservative college
we're waiting for we're waiting for
someone to correct us we've done some
research we have never found anything
been closed yeah now have two thousand
six hundred and fifty students from all
50 states no one's really found anything
even comparable of size so we call it
the largest until someone corrects us
yeah well there were you had some
protesters out there yeah they they show
up all the time to everything there but
but there was true diversity of thought
there okay
you it was also sort of a Rubin report
reunion for me because Prager was there
and Gutfeld was there all my best friend
Candace was there obviously and and a
whole bunch of others chervil clunk Jr
was there is just a series of people I
went up there and I talked about being
gay married and I talked about being
pro-choice and a bunch of other things
that if you were to poll the average
conservative that perhaps they're not
for I think gay marriage maybe it's a
little a little different at this point
but I got a standing ovation and
everywhere that I multiple times oh yeah
yeah budget times and
everywhere that I went for those two
three days that I was there and been by
no means was this just me I mean Ben
Shapiro came out it was like it was like
Elvis it was oh yeah I'm gonna say it
was like Rolling Stones seriously is nut
but that happened to everybody I went
for breakfast I need coffee before I
talk to people yet I'm literally there's
a line of 100 people start popping up
it's like they start swarming yeah but
that said something to me beyond the
politics that there's something else
going on with young people right now
where they actually as the young people
say they're they're really woke yes
what's happening here well and it's that
diversity idea is that I think
illustrates what makes our organization
so unique so a reporter came up to me
and he was totally dishonest guys like
well this this feels like a Donald Trump
rally and I said how could you possibly
say that sure we have Trump jr. we have
Gorka we also Austin Peterson I ran for
president on in the libertarian Park all
right we have Ruben who is not a leftist
anymore but he's somewhere out there
right he believes in freedom Yeah right
we've been Shapiro who literally led the
never trumpet right we have a huge
diversity of ideas and each speaker was
respected was given standing ovations
was challenged appropriately and I think
that really says something about this
new conservatory and movement that we're
helping create yeah which is we don't
have to agree on 100% of conservative
dogma let's just get the big stuff right
the big stuff is America a great country
yes it's free enterprise a good thing
yes you know its freedom something that
we should really embrace as a general
idea yes is socialism bad yes that's
just pretty much the main key points and
the rest of the stuff we can argue and
disagree with respectfully yeah when did
you wake up to some of these stuffs just
tell me a little bit of sure growing up
and your I was crazy crazy kid growing
up grew up in the northwest suburbs of
Chicago always was a conservative
Republican growing up around a lot of
leftists and liberals yeah in my public
high school and our you young and
conservative like I because I love
history and I was always contrarian
right so I'd always be challenging my
teachers my parents were generally
Republican right they weren't you know
necessarily political but they were
center-right O'Reilly Factor watching
you know Republic
I always used to say and then I would
always just challenge teachers that
would say that you know all
conservatives want to do is kill poor
people and you know pollute the
environment the typical talking points
right and being the kind of you know
rebel I guess you could say I'd always
challenge the teachers and say well no
Ronald Reagan lifted more people out of
poverty than your crazy social programs
that Jimmy Carter drove nuts and I found
enjoyment in it and you know the further
down that rabbit hole you get the more
you read Milton Friedman the more you
understand the foundational principles
and ideas at a young age I just became
on fire for politics and for economics
and long story short I started this
organization when I was 18 instead of
going to college and ended up being a
wonderful decision and helped really
place myself in a movement that was
waiting to be grown and this is
something a lot bigger than just
politics this is the fight for the soul
of the country and it has to start on
college campuses and it's really the
struggle for our generation and it's
it's really if you divide it it's do we
want do we believe America is the
greatest country in the history of the
world and do we believe freedom is a
good thing or do we want to go a
completely different direction that
looks much more like a European
socialist democracy that does not honor
civil liberties that does not honor
private property and really deteriorates
everything that made America a great
place that that's the decision our
generation has to make it's kind of
funny you're sort of like the non
Silicon Valley version of like Bill
Gates or Steve Jobs that didn't quite
flattering did you go to college or
dropped out of college and but now
you're talking to college people when
did you realize that that was the place
that that this battle had to be yeah the
first couple years of starting
turning-point USA it started as kind of
a generic student organization but just
like any good innovator and entrepreneur
I listened and I learned and I realized
there was such frustration amongst
self-identified conservative
libertarians on campus that were not
being properly channeled and organized
they felt as if they were being targeted
and that they were being suppressed and
their ideas were not being allowed to be
heard and we made a decision that
turning point in the for a couple years
is let's not just fight the political
war let's double down and fight the
culture war and that we can be the
champions of free speech and we can be
the ambassadors of freedom where really
you see these campuses I call them
Islands a totalitarian is
you know their idea of diversity is a
group of people that all look different
but they think the same yeah that's not
diversity and so turning-point has
benefitted tremendously over the last
couple years of really being the
champions of free speech and also saying
hey we're not Republicans we're not
conservatives we're not libertarians you
can call us all that stuff that's fine
we have members that are across that
whole spectrum as long as you believe in
freedom you believe America is a great
country welcome aboard
do you think the idea of having that
kind of wide tent is part of the appeal
like I think people are so sick of the
labels and all that was cool
I spend actually most of the weekend
hanging out with with Austin but part of
it also hanging out with Tommy and
Candice and a whole bunch of other
people and I was like there really is
and then and then you know Allison
Stuckey was there and a couple other
people and I was like wow these people
actually really do think different
things totally and and my libertarian
side usually goes to kind of where
Austin that but I was like we we're all
having dinner after that's a great thing
and I was like this is great we're
having real discussion yeah we're really
digging into it and there is that
disagreement but if you put them all in
a room they but they get the big stuff
right yeah right you know do we believe
that free enterprise has been a net
positive for humanity do we believe the
Constitution is a great political
document that should be preserved
protected and better understood do we
believe America has been a wonderful you
know net benefit for Humanity you know
over the last 200 years they probably
agree wholeheartedly and all that it's
the other stuff where they start to have
little philosophical differences but
that disagreement is not being found on
the left right now if you disagree with
one core tenets of leftist dogma you're
ostracized you're kicked out and that
shows they're they're not a diverse
political movement the new modern
American Left they're extremely
intolerant of differing opinions and I
don't have to talk for yeah I mean I'll
just let you think that you're acting as
my agent but listen I would gladly I
said this when I had Shapiro on last
week I will gladly give the exact same
speech that I gave to you guys a couple
weeks ago I would love to give that
exact same speech to any progressive or
Democrat and you got a standing ovation
but I'm looking to go with my mag a hat
wearing students right but you give that
speech to the young Democrat socialist
of America conference coming up in a
couple months
you'll get boos and you'll get
shouldn't hear things we disagree with
yeah you know bolshevik you know forever
it's these people have have translated
into total authoritarianism do you see a
moment where both of the movements sort
of where you would argue the
Conservatives sort of lost their place
thus lost the culture war or and where
they left sort of went bananas yeah I
think the length has gone bananas just
by default of their positions they
really inside of every leftist is a
totalitarian waiting this you know
screaming to get out is a great quote I
always use yeah it's because when you
argue for total government power and
total government control of health care
and schools and private economic
decisions that can easily be translated
into the monitoring of personal capacity
decisions right that that translation is
quite simple and I always say to a
leftist that says well I believe in you
know civil liberties but I also believe
in government-run schools and health
care as I say if you don't trust the
government to help you know to monitor
your own personal life wine earth when
you trust the government throughout all
these other institutions where I think
conservatives have gotten it wrong over
the last thirty years is where
conservatives have become mislabeled and
sometimes some considers believe this to
want to do social engineering I think
I'm gonna have angelical Christian I'm a
pro-life conservative but I also believe
government should have barriers in
trying to instill those values upon
society I think the best persuasion the
best capacity for good is done through
churches and local community movements
and individuals persuading individuals
and writing books and doing podcasts not
through government doing massive social
engineering programs so I think that's
where conservatives have lost their way
and that's where the left is currently
trying to stake their claim is there
anything that you think government does
well no no I think government is a
necessary evil I think it's necessary
for providing from the National Defense
because that is something that whether
we like it or not you have to you have
to delegate some of our personal freedom
to you know have a some sort of a civil
society but government by its essence if
you read what Milton Friedman has said
they're incentivized to be inefficient
they're incentivized by definition to
not be able to provide the best possible
good or service for the individual so
look the private sector does everything
better whether it be the inefficiency
post office Medicare is bankrupt Social
Security doesn't serve the people you
know effectively everything government
touches goes to crap and the private
sector is by definition more efficient
because if you don't do it well you're
not going to exist much longer what do
you think is the best way of getting
that message across that government just
doesn't do things well because I think
it's just so built-in to people partly
because our education is sure-tan
screwed up or whatever that they just
feel the government should just do
things so I saw Bernie tweeted the other
day this video of all these millionaires
saying I responded yeah so I retweeted
it which got like twenty thousand
retweets because it was like it's all
these millionaires saying we should be
taxed more we should be taxed more well
what what intellectual hip-hop it's such
lies it's like boy a what's stopping you
from pay that's what I see boys just
send more money to the IRS numbskull or
it's right but it's like but okay so but
yet
Bernie's tweet gets something like fifty
thousand retweets and not that it's all
about retweets and all but it's true he
has high engagement with this but to me
it's just lazy thinking it is lazy so
virtuous if it's so virtuous to keep
giving money to the gods right why do
you need the government to tell you to
do it and really at its core if you look
at the philosophical difference between
really the culturally Marxist left which
is what they're becoming and the free
thinking individualist you know
individual libertarian conservative
right which is the new you know
intellectual position that is growing
you know quicker than even the left it's
we might want good things to happen in
society but don't tell me to do them at
gunpoint yeah and the left on the other
hand I don't think their intentions are
very good I think they want permanent
political power but Bernie Sanders for
example he's so convicted that he is
right he wants to use the absolute
authority on and unlimited power of the
state to put a gun to your head and say
you have to have a 70 percent tax rate
because someone is starving on the
street I would rather live in a society
that has the same tax rate for everyone
10% and we dig deep we say are we gonna
take care of that person on the street
through charity through private
philanthropy and through being better
people and if you look at when
socialism's implemented you see the
moral disintegration of society you look
at Spain you look at France you look at
Europe they don't have anything as
private philanthropy anymore private
charity has
in Europe because government takes care
of it and that I think that is such an
important point to make so going back to
your question how do you illustrate this
to a young person you asked the
fundamental question do you trust a
government that word Trust is so
important because in in that word trust
that really feels personal all right do
you trust the government 99% of young
people will say no then you ask the next
question then why do you want to make
government bigger as soon it and they'll
say I don't well then you're not a
social so you're not a leftist then
let's talk about how we can really
shrink the size of government and put
power back into the hands of people and
it's important to note also even though
you think government might want to do
something doesn't mean federal
government has to do it local government
is much more accountable to the citizens
than some bureaucrat in DC that you're
never going to meet and so those are
those are arguments that you know we've
found to be very effective yeah it's
interesting you mentioned intentions and
I always try my best not to impugn
intentions of others I think that
especially on the left right now
obviously I think these people have a
lot of bad ideas now of course some of
them have bad intentions but most of
them don't most average people don't
wake up thinking we're I'm gonna do bad
today they actually think they're doing
good most of them yeah do you think some
of their leaders actually have bad and
without a doubt yes absolutely and not
all of them but some of them and you
look back to the original writings and
the original thought process behind the
Great Society Lyndon Baines Johnson who
bragged on multiple times that the
implementation the Great Society and all
the social programs around it will keep
african-americans dependent and keep
them voting for generations documented
in the presidential record Lyndon Baines
Johnson said that and so I think the
Democratic Party is full of people with
great intentions but its leaders have
realized and calculated but if they can
keep the government programs continuing
for just long enough not getting people
out of poverty but keep people surviving
within poverty they will have a
permanent political base so if you ask
the question if African Americans
actually rose out of poverty and saw
their wages get higher and their schools
get better and their communities you
know flourish are they going to keep
voting for government welfare programs
that are the basis of the Democratic
Party absolutely not
they're not they're gonna break out of
that so I think the intentions of the
Democratic Party
the followers I'm never ever going to
impugn them I'm not going to call them
deplorable Zoar anything
like they call us I think most of the
followers Democratic Party actually
really good people but the leaders we
must question their motives because if
you look at the failures of the welfare
system in this country it is undoubtable
that they're protecting a system that
benefits them politically is this also
partly why the media is going so
hysterical right now like have you
noticed just in the last couple of weeks
we've shifted a little bit out of Russia
hysteria but now it's about Trump's
mental capacity and they and it's like
wow and see how they coordinate it I
mean you really if you just look I'm
telling you they got they got like a
group text message chain going I'm
telling they got like John King Anderson
Cooper Don Lemon Rachel Maddow I think
they're all just group texting I'm not
kidding I want to go down that
conspiracy theory can you I mean when
you start to have all three television
stations open of CBS this morning and
CNN you know with Cuomo and MSNBC The
Morning Joe and they're talking about
the exact same thing literally the
segment's are literally produced the
same I don't think that's a conspiracy
it there's got to be some sort of
Talking Points Memo they send out just
this early in the morning but does that
show you were talking points memo or
just general group thing no I think it's
general group event but they also I
think they understand that they have to
be coordinated to be effective which
there's nothing I think wrong with that
effectively we conservatives do the same
thing without even realizing it you
listen to Rush Limbaugh you listen to
Dennis Prager and you listen to Sean
Hannity the talking points are usually
quite similar because you know you watch
Fox and Friends in the morning that kind
of sets the agenda and I'm not I'm not
attacking the Democrats for being that
but if you look at why the media is
going so far off the rails it's they
will never accept the fact that this
presidencies actually large in part a
wonderful success is that the president
is fulfilling his campaign promises
we're seeing unprecedented economic
prosperity and you're seeing people's
lives actually get better and so they
have to go down to this tabloid
journalism a report on this fake book
they have to continue down this Russia
hysteria because if this president
succeeds which he is and he will what
else do they have they have gone so far
all in that this guy is a psychopathic
nutjob they will they will lose all
institutional credibility and political
relevance you know it's funny right when
Trump started the campaign I kept saying
that if you keep calling this guy Hitler
you are painting yourself into a really
bad corner and it cheapens Hitler to yak
about that
was one of the worst mass murderers in
human history who killed 15 million
people and they have people once a week
on those networks equate him to the rise
of the Third Reich what does that do is
it cheapens the evil of Hitler and isn't
that one of the worst things you could
possibly do more trying to educate the
next generation
everyone's Hitler no one's Hitler the
maybe what Hitler did wasn't that bad
maybe Hitler was democratically elected
and had a Supreme Court that kept them
in balance you see what I'm saying that
right you know it cheapens the evil of
the Nazi Empire when they start to make
these comparisons to Donald Trump and
Hitler it's really and and also the way
this stuff just goes downstream I mean
because then it's you start calling all
your intellectual opponents Nazis then
you say it's okay to punch Nazis well
where does that end can we punch the
knots and life can we blow up there
exactly I'm called a Nazi all the time
and I mean it's one of the most
intellectually just dangerous arguments
to make when you and when everyone
becomes a fascist even though there is
no evidence of that what really has your
political movement become yeah where'd
the words freedom and liberty and the
words that I now use a lot how did they
get so MUC tup that they started feeling
wrong you know demeaning the cultural
relevance of things well I think it I
think it's starting with the
misrepresentation of what freedom and
liberty really is I mean the left tries
to be the movement of freedom a lot of
young people that follow Bernie Sanders
actually think they're on the side of
freedom they think that Bernie Sanders
is fighting for political freedom and
economic freedom and that he's gonna
fight for the little guy when in reality
when his ideas are implemented which
he's an open socialist the power always
gets concentrated at the top the rulers
are the ones that get rich the people
that have the best connections the best
lobbyists are the ones that benefit
tremendously you look no further than
Venezuela or Cuba or anywhere where
socialism is tried it's the poor people
that voted these guys into power they
could that are worst off mmm-hmm and so
we have to be able to make the argument
freedom is not only a really cool thing
freedom is not only a great idea but it
actually works like freedom when
implemented actually makes people's
lives better it you know freedom would
be a difficult argument if it was not
only like really cool to make the
argument like yeah
you do whatever you want to do when you
want to do it how you want to do it that
would be great yeah but we actually get
to make the argument that in
practicality freedom is the greatest
thing to make people's lives better for
innovations for medical advances for
technological you know prosperity
nothing comes even close to allowing
freedom to to ensue so what do you say
when someone says I hear this all the
time you know well if the government
doesn't do these things these social
programs or if the government takes away
food stamps or whatever it is that we
just don't know if the private sector or
churches and synagogues whatever we just
don't know that that'll pick up the
slack and then if that doesn't happen we
end up with this permanent class of
under underserved people that have no
way so fundamentally disagree with that
and so this is where the world views I
think collide is where the left they try
to build this I think a lot of it is
trying for guilt right they actually
want to help as many people as possible
they feel so bad that people are
suffering they want someone else that do
it for them so the first thing I do is I
challenge how much money are you giving
to charity how much are you doing
actually help the homeless guy in the
side corner yeah and then what if ten
million people did what you did secondly
never underestimate the good that
Americans will do when people are in
need
hurricanes natural disasters famines
fires Americans always step up Americans
voluntarily gave 500 billion dollars
away to charity last year imagine if our
tax rate was 10 percent imagine if there
was really a national rallying call to
double our charitable efforts we can
easily get away trillions of dollars Wow
trillions of dollars that's the size of
the welfare state and I would make a
compelling argument that local churches
charities and municipalities do a heck
of a lot better job of serving the
people than the federal government
bureaucrat a lot better you know sending
money to Washington DC is that actually
gonna help the poor single mother in
Miami or is going to the local Catholic
Church and getting $5,000
which might be a lot of money to you
actually gonna help them a lot more than
send that $5,000 Washington DC I will
argue fiercely against someone who says
that a government bureaucrat is going to
help an underprivileged individual
better than a private charity or
individuals helping individuals so you
said a couple nice things about Trump so
I want to get into some of this
the specifics on that please but so one
of the things that I've said is that
Trump basically was the bull in the
china shop and he just went in and just
up and did everything and I actually
think that right now that's a net good
because there were a lot of bad things
happening before there's some fertile
ground for good ideas so on that level
I'm for what's happening when I had Eric
Weinstein sitting in that chair he said
that he would have preferred it to be a
panther in a china shop meaning it would
have just knocked over a few things
maybe not all there I don't think that
that exists that's that was the point of
our disagreement I just think it just
doesn't exist where you get to
selectively choose where things are
gonna be knocked off the shelves and all
that said Gorka was speaking at the
turning point of entry good gutfeld was
doing this whole thing about how some
lady was doing it backstage continued on
stuff it's not but but gorko is saying
how Trump was the I think he said the
Icebreaker going sure the glacier
basically and what I noticed that was
there was a theme with the speakers
where everyone basically acknowledged
that there are issues with Trump I don't
think anyone went up there and said this
guy is the perfect thing or you know
this is exactly how we wanted it but
there was a sense of this was the only
way it could have happened is that
basically where you fall so I'm one of
the few you know outward and vocal
millennial Trump you know supporters out
there not few I should say in kind of
this work world a conservative pundit
tree if you will everyone tries the
heads right and there's some good and
some bad and I've obviously gone all in
and I'm glad I have and I'm happy to
walk through you know the philosophical
you know reasoning for that so look look
Donald Trump was never supposed to be
president at States just look going back
a little bit running in a crowded field
of Republican candidates announcing the
day after Jeb Bush announced his
candidacy which I think was no
coincidence and I think he saw Jeb Bush
announced like screw it if that guy's
running I'm running took down the bush
dynasty that out a hundred ten million
dollars to spend and then took down the
Clinton dynasty took down the media
dynasty in a way that's totally
unprecedented and if you look at the
values that he represents in my personal
opinion he is one of the best chances
Western civilization has to continue he
believes America is the greatest country
in the history of the world he's been a
fierce critic of socialism his visit
this Poland
a 40-minute critique of the fall of the
USSR he believes that the Constitution's
the greatest political document ever
written look no further than his
appointment of Gorsuch in these Circuit
Court judges more than any of that he
believes that America as an idea must be
preserved protected and advanced and is
he an imperfect vessel of course we're
all imperfect vessels does he tweet
things that I might not always agree
with yeah sure
but but if the ideas that he's
implementing I would make a compelling
argument he's the most conservative
president in a hundred years even more
so than Ronald Reagan he is doing more
bold reforms and he's fighting to do
what he said he was going to do even in
the face of unprecedented opposition
whether it be the embassy moving to
Jerusalem opening up our natural
resources getting out of TPP getting out
of the Paris climate Court agreement
this is stuff that is not supposed to
happen right do you think Jeb Bush would
be doing this summit give me a break no
way so basically do you think he was the
last chance for conservatives I think I
say that good I kind of think that's a
compelling argument that know that if
you look when McCain ran or Romney ran
Romney was against women with his
binders of women they said you know
McCain was racist blah blah blah
that to me the most compelling argument
is that none of these guy you think
Marco Rubio will beat Hillary I know or
Jeb would is somehow beat Hillary know
so that putting aside some of my
reservations for a moment this was the
only way that any of these ideas were
gonna get that bet that's correct so we
play out the alternative scenario
Hillary Clinton is president and she has
control the Senate and control the house
and she's just advancing this radically
destructive Obama agenda instead Donald
Trump for any of the disagreements
people might have around him the results
really speak for themselves the economic
prosperity that we're seeing right now
that you can six trillion dollars of new
wealth created in this country but even
more than that I'm telling you there was
a referendum on the ballot and I was
there on Wisconsin I was there in
Michigan I was there in Pennsylvania
with Donald Trump jr. for weeks on end
the people that showed up to vote that
hand vote in 30 years see what they were
really voting for they were voting that
America is the greatest country that has
through the world and here's finally
someone who's gonna fiercely defend it
against the permanent political class
that's important because who else to
represent that permanent political class
than Hillary Clinton like she was the
worst
and the Democrats could have put up in a
change election here's someone whose
husband was impeached who constantly
cheated on her she's the most
uncharismatic possible person to put up
and here's a guy who you know what he's
gonna blow it up great that's who I'm
gonna vote for and you look a lot of
what he's doing he has shrunk the size a
lot of these federal bureaucracies and
he's fighting a lot of these entrenched
media and political establishments that
honestly I never thought we would see
such a champion against which brings me
great satisfaction what do you think
about the intellectual side of Trump
like I get what you're saying you that
the broad ideas of freedom in America
and liberty and those things and I
basically agree that that's he does
understand those things in terms of just
like the intellectual or philosophical
side do you think he really has an
understanding of the issues or do you
think that maybe isn't even important I
don't think it's that important I've
spent considerable time with him and his
family and I can say this his his
understanding of why America is the
greatest country in the history of the
world why free enterprise matters and
actually how to benefit country as a
whole is is just as good if not better
than some of these politicians I might
be able to recite all these intellectual
and philosophical quotes because this is
a president that you know what he's been
through bankruptcy trials he's been
through hiring and firing hundreds of
people and you know you running a
business and me running a business that
develops character in someone you just
got to say making payroll dealing with
regulators - versus some of these
senators that have been you know orders
and thinkers their whole life give me a
break right so I have a deep amount of
respect it doesn't bother me that you
know CNN says that we talks at a fourth
grade level give me a break you know
seriously he talks the way that the guy
in Northeast Iowa has been waiting for
someone to talk to in a while so I
completely dismissed that as an argument
and I look at what he's accomplished as
a person which is totally amazing and
what he's fighting for every single day
and he gets the big stuff correct he
really does and I challenge some of my
you know critics on the right who else
in that field the 17 Republican
candidates would have nominated gorse if
the Supreme Court moved the embassy
advocated for the greatest you know
middle-class tax cut in American history
not back down on some of these core
issues it's really if I would have said
here's XYZ candidate let's just pretend
this is you know in the Republican
primary and in the first 11 months we'd
get this done most conservative pundits
where do I sign you know seriously you
know and he has he has advanced more
conservative pro-freedom libertarian
ideas than any of these candidates well
most of these candidates would so then
what do you make of the conservative
class that hates him so I'm talking
about like the David Frum crew that that
whole yeah French the rest of these guys
that really just hate him even though I
agree he has put forth a lot of the idea
that they've been yammering about for
the last twenty years I mean look I have
a lot of respect for those publications
because of their history I'm just I'm
challenged I I'm really wondering is it
a personal vendetta they have against
this guy is it a personality
disagreement because policy wise and
implementation of the people he's put in
place to make decisions the cabinet
positions I mean this is a much more
conservative president than george w
bush and remarkably more effective than
HW and already in 12 months much more
consequential than ronald reagan and and
so i i'm wondering i want the balls in
their court right because to be so hyper
critical just automatically against
someone who is fighting for your ideas
every single day i I'm just I'm really
wondering what was it is it a
personality disagreement or is it kind
of just I don't want to be wrong type of
thing like I'm cheering for his demise
because I'm a posed him for so long I
think it's also I just want to be liked
by mainstream which is the other thing
right like I I've now created a whole
new form of enemies I never thought
possible which is like these rabid
welcome to my world you know serious
like these rabid media elites that are
like always close to the Trump people we
must try to destroy him I'm like alright
fine whatever you know yeah the hatred
for this man is is uncalled for is there
anything that he's doing that you're not
happy with so I'll give you a that's a
great question I so I'll give you
something that just in the last you know
what you're gonna say and I'll probably
agree okay so in the last 10 days so he
basically instructed Jeff Sessions so
that we're gonna agree on okay so to me
states rights if you care about that
constant fear and that you said he loves
so much and all those things the states
should be able to make laws that they
want and the federal government should
not impede on the library we have
something called the Tenth Amendment etc
etc so in a case like this what's
happening there how is there such a
disconnect between the ideas of freedom
that you're laid out so eloquently and
then what sessions is doing
practice I can't I can't explain it well
and I won't defend it cuz I don't agree
with it look I'm a big defender of
individual freedom and liberty and I get
a lot of hate from my social skin sick
conservative friends when I argue for
decriminalization of drugs I've never
done drugs in my life and I don't plan
to but someone wants to do it
cool right whatever you know put
whatever you want to put in your bodies
along it doesn't harm someone else so
this is something that I think actually
not making the correct decision on but
you know what I'm happy to say that said
it publicly and you know if I if I find
someone like Jeff session who's gets
most of the stuff right he's been great
on guns he's been great on some of the
other stuff but I don't think he's
correct on this this marijuana issue and
I don't think he's correct politically
it says the majority of Americans don't
agree on this issue and to go after
people that are peacefully doing
business that's really what they're
going after this is the financial
transaction side that doesn't make a lot
of sense to me that's not on the correct
side of economic freedom but you know
what disagreement is a healthy thing
right and we need to challenge our
cabinet officials and challenge our
leaders when we don't see eye to eye
with them and I think this is something
that I think runs in the face of some of
our core beliefs and tenants yeah it
just seems like so ideologically
inconsistent when I think it's fighting
for states right he's been fighting for
Sates rights in that it look even now
you've got people on the Left fighting
for slaves right ridiculous which makes
no sense because now they're they're
trying to defend sanctuary cities so now
therefore doesn't make it right and
against the federal government right
doesn't make any sense but I will say
this I think a lot of it is stemmed from
this kind of old holdover war on drugs
that Ronald Reagan declared in the 1980s
which was an abysmal and total failure
right the statistics speak for
themselves that you know the war on
recreational marijuana has not been a
net benefit for the taxpayer for society
in general again I come from the general
worldview that the greatest change does
not come through government policy or
through government bureaucrats and sort
of be intellectually consistent I won't
defend penalizing people that are
peacefully selling you know cannabis to
other people whether it be for medically
recreationally and but here's the thing
I went to high school in Northwest
arbors of Chicago this is the story I
always tell people say Charlie you're a
conservative how can you possibly hold
its position oh that's always at these
Tea Party groups which I love I love the
tea party I love those people right but
they're they're my you know I call them
like the hard core group right like
they're the Alex Jones you know
flag-carrying people that are really
core they're really big in the
conspiracy and you know there's there
always ask me Charlie how can you
possibly be on the side of
decriminalization of marijuana I said
listen I went to high school in the
north the suburbs of Chicago okay
I remember after football games like
kids have backpacks full of marijuana
now marijuana is illegal in Illinois
marijuana is illegal in Cook County and
there were cops in our halls looking for
it all the time it was not working okay
okay let's just put it that way the Reds
are one and it found it the kids like me
who didn't want anything to do with it
just walked away what what other better
illustration of freedom than that you
don't want to engage with it just walk
away find somewhere else to do it we
didn't need to pay you know the DEA or
FBI units to go do locker room raids of
something that kids were recreationally
and peacefully doing I'm not a proponent
of it I would support a charity to try
to educate students not to do it cuz I
think of Rupe you know had a net
negative but why is it government's role
to socially engineer us especially when
it's a non-lethal substance I always
think it's so interesting like okay now
I'm in California where it's now yeah
now recreationally legal but I have a
medical marijuana card and I've hurt my
knee playing bass yeah well a couple
years ago the places right over there
I'd like to walk you in there just to
see what's going on before look you're
not gonna persuade me to it's fine
whatever I just think it would be fun to
go in there with you and yeah that would
be what was going on and go where my mag
I had that would not go well no no it's
not that I would get a hit of salt there
but I think it's funny because anytime
that I ever bought weed illegally like
when I lived in York City yeah just get
it from whoever the weed guy was I don't
even know who that we've got exactly but
I never once in 15 years or whatever I
never had the guy selling weed say hey
you want to buy crack you want to buy
coke you want right now and yet we can
go to prescription plate you can go to a
psychiatrist will push every drug and
it's a hundred times worse and it's and
it's chemically addictive yeah right so
look I know plenty of people that have
had stories that tell me Charlie if it
wasn't for medicinal marijuana I would
have gone to narco substances and I
would have been a really a worse place
right and so fine but that's the core
tenant of freedom and I think what
you're seeing here is most of our
turning point followers would find
sympathy with my argument and this is
okay this is a natural change in a
political movement as time goes on but
and the fact that jeff sessions
hold that position maybe he has an
experience that I haven't experienced
right that is really personal to him
maybe he's seen you know marijuana do
something horrible to a family member of
people and local community Alabama I'll
disagree with that probably not like
whatever I'm trying to give the benefit
the doubt because I think he's generally
a good person I always try to give the
benefit out when people hold these
positions yeah I just think it's not the
right policy but you know what in 20
years you're gonna see the conservative
libertarian majority similar to Rand
Paul advocate for this and then we'll be
able to point out the hypocrisy the
left's say okay hold on a second like
we're cool with people being able to
sell what they want to sell long doesn't
harm someone else why are you trying to
tell me I can't frack this oil field in
the Permian Basin right right if you
want to have like it into it if you want
to be intellectually consistent right
huh
all right I want to do one other thing
on the social stuff and then we'll move
over to some articles oh no I know I
said listen I never had like yes the
questions don't you immediately sat down
you're like anything let's go all right
seriously challenge me here we are so
well I don't think this want to be too
much of a challenge but I think it's an
interesting shirt it just shows how
things have shifted so at the Republican
convention Peter Thiel an openly gay man
great link spoke before Trump he said
I'm a proud gay man got a standing
ovation
then Trump gets up there talks about
weights him out yeah TRO right points a
man he said it makes me very happy with
any exact quote he said because he other
makes me very happy that was a hand okay
what's that that the fact that there's
been such a wholesale shift in that that
even right now Ted Cruz or the guys that
you might consider a little more of the
Christian conservatives without Mike
Huckabee right okay so so where you come
from basically as far as I can tell
don't really see this as an issue
anymore is that a fair price that's
correct
and and so let me dive deeper and also
pose a hypothetical to some of the
leftists watching this Peter teal openly
gay man gets a standing ovation at the
Republican National Convention and then
pointed as the you know pointed out by
the candidate do you think that an
evangelical pastor that was pro-israel
that might be a Democrat would have even
been allowed to speak at the Democratic
National Convention or given a standing
ovation they booed God he was doing that
was when it was mentioned okay
they literally did
what is the shift here the shift is the
Republican Party is beginning to realize
hey let's party of freedom like it's
cool if you want to do that I think it's
it's a real sea change because even if
you see Rand Paul beginning to you know
endorse more of those you know favorable
drug policy positions on the side of
freedom or gay marriage you know you're
starting to see a sea change where it's
becoming the soul-searching the
Republican Party as we donor the last
thirty years is what's the one thing
that ties our party together freedom
freedom freedom and I think that's why
you're starting to see that and the left
they can't reconcile what ties them
together oppression you know like it's
the oppression Olympics if I gotta
suffers more you know and I think that's
a really good thing segue to one one
final point is what I think is the
position that needs to be articulated
better is I have no problem if you know
gay marriage whatever like I believe
marriage one man one woman that's my own
personal position right but I'm never
gonna tell government to have someone
live a life I think it's cool you're
married I think it's great and you
should have all the same tax benefits
adopt children it's great right but now
you feel the same way about you well
it's fine like whatever like but that's
that's more of like a generational
perspective here's where I think
Republican conservatives need to really
fight hard and I think you agree is the
religious liberty stuff is are you gonna
force a Christian Baker to make a cake
for a gay couple that is not the same
thing as being cool with gay marriage
yeah and the left is trying to make a
moral equivalency argument of the civil
rights of in the 1960s and someone
having to violate the religious
conscience to make a cake for a gay
couple because they want to and they
want to have fascism where you can go
into a private company and say you have
to produce a product or service because
we have a certain you know lifestyle
that's dangerous and wrong and I think
that's where the fight needs to happen
and that's where I think we can actually
win conference over do you think also
that technology is the answer to some of
those problems where we've kind of sucks
that you know I did in my Prager you
video from last year which was excellent
thanks I mean that was the line that
really caught on because I don't want to
force know that Baker to do something
just as if there was a
you could use any example here but if
there was a Jewish artist who had a
website that they take commissions for
paintings I wouldn't want the government
forcing them to paint neo-nazi paintings
I think it's exactly the same thing yeah
and would you want to force you know a
Muslim wedding hall to have to host you
know someone that is a great critic of
Islam right that would violate one of
the tenants one of the pillars of Islam
right but for whatever reason the left
is you know way overstepping their
bounds in the Circuit Court of
California is like lost their freaking
mind seriously where they don't realize
the slippery slope that they're engaging
in here where if you have a private
business with their own private
conscience they should be allowed to
accept and deny business as they see fit
especially if it's business that takes
pre-planning and like such as a wedding
cake or photography the only argument
they might make is if you're you know
running a fast food restaurant but you
know what if someone wants to be a
racist or a bigot they have that right
no one's gonna go buy products from them
anymore right
that's how you win arguments without
having to use the government gun on
people's heads which again I think
that's the argument that we have to make
but if look if a gay couple wants to get
married that's cool like whatever that's
the law of the land move on to bigger
battles like religious liberty and
freedom
[Music]
you
[Music]